adele is giving fans a rare look at her
relationship with boyfriend rich paul
she shared five sweet snapshots to
instagram on wednesday
in the first image the pair poses with
what looks like house keys suggesting
they've moved in together while we wait
for official confirmation on that i'm
very very humbled another pick appears
to be backstage at a venue where rich
leans over to show his girlfriend adele
some affection the caption for these
cute shots time flies
[Music]
adele and rich paul first fueled romance
rumors in july of 2021 when they were
spotted together in arizona at a game
for the nba finals
and at the 2022 brit awards the singer
sparked engagement rumors after she wore
a massive diamond ring on her ring
finger
soon after being spotted with the huge
rock adele played coy after being
directly asked if she's headed for the
altar during an appearance on the graham
norton show when you were sat on the
piano singing at microphone in right
hand i thought left hand didn't move as
much as normal it seemed heavier
than normal
is there i mean as if i would ever tell
anyone if i was or wasn't
nice move adele it's been a complete
whirlwind following the speculation the
couple celebrated date night at the nba
all-star game in late february where
rich and adele were spotted getting cozy
together
[Music]
as far as what adele and rich paul's
future potentially looks like here's
what she told graham about her plans to
expand her family i want a baby next
year
i have plans next year i have a plan
imagine if i have to cancel shows having
a baby
[Music]